se cumple otro aniversario de tiananmen
con sordina porque el asunto sigue
siendo un tabú aquí 33 años después no
ha habido ninguna referencia en la
prensa nacional todas las alusiones en
internet han quedado censuradas y han
aumentado las medidas de seguridad en
los accesos a la plaza donde hoy era
evidente que había más policía y se
habían instalado además cámaras de
reconocimiento facial nada de eso es
nuevo en la china continental si es más
reciente en hong kong donde hasta no
hace tanto tiempo se podía recordar aún
la matanza de tiananmen especialmente
con las vigilias de velas encendidas en
el parque victoria en memoria de los
caídos esa práctica quedó prohibida a
raíz de la aprobación de la ley de
seguridad nacional en 2019 siempre con
la excusa de los peligros del
coronavirus el grupo que organizaba esas
vigilias el alianza de hong kong ha sido
perseguido por ser un agente extranjero
en tareas de incitación de la subversión
la policía ha desaconsejado a la
ciudadanía que participe en asambleas
ilegales y ha amenazado con detenciones
así que también en hong kong se
desvanece la huella de tiananmen como
demuestra la retirada de monumentos
conmemorativos de los campos
universitarios